let's speak to skies lisa dowd who has
been following proceedings at coventry
crown court and can tell us more lisa
yes emma tustin was found guilty of the
murder of six-year-old arthur arthur's
father was found guilty of his
manslaughter it took the jury just six
hours and 15 minutes to come to their
conclusion we couldn't see any reaction
from the defendants in court they were
in a separate court due to covid but
there were grandparents and uncles who
were in court and they had their heads
bowed as those verdicts came in
and something quite unprecedented
actually after the jurors had delivered
those verdicts they asked for a minute
silence to remember arthur so
terrible is some of the evidence that
they have seen
and heard during this very lengthy case
now to give you some of the background
to this case it was locked down
march 2020 when those unprecedented
restrictions came in to tackle the
pandemic
as a result
arthur and his dad moved in with
his relatively new girlfriend emma
tustin to her home in sully hall at that
point arthur was a healthy and cherished
little boy by his wider family
but in the weeks that followed one
witness described him as broken he was
subjected to a campaign of abuse that
the prosecution said
amounted to torture by those who should
have cared for him and then by june 2020
little arthur had succumbed to an
unsurvivable brain injury which was
inflicted by tustin as well as the
beatings he endured from his father and
his girlfriend emma tustin was also
found guilty today
of withholding food and drink
to arthur and also poisoning him with
salt by lacing his food
with salt and forcing him to eat it now
this all in spite of social workers
being alerted to his case by a concerned
family member who had noticed some
bruising they had notified police about
this bruising they've notified social
workers
but when social workers went round to
the house in april they found no cause
for concern they found what they
described as a happy household everybody
was getting along and they and police
took no further action a few months
later little arthur was dead now whether
more could have been done will be
subject to an independent safeguarding
review
here is stephen cullen who is the chair
of the solihull
child safeguarding partnership
this terrible tragedy has had a shocking
impact on arthur's family and across the
whole community
the tragic loss of a young boy in such
terrible circumstances is dreadful
we send our heartfelt condolences to
everybody affected
the circumstances around the death will
be now subject of independent review
the local child safeguarding practice
review
and clearly it would be inappropriate
for the partnership
to comment ahead of the findings of this
review
now tustin and hughes will be sentenced
tomorrow the judge has said um there are
some terrible details to this case much
of it was caught on cctv camera because
the couple had rigged a camera up in
their lounge where they'd made arthur
sleep on the floor downstairs on his own
and they had recorded their punishment
so the court has heard audio of him
saying that no one loved him and begging
for food and drink and so traumatized
have the jury been by what they've heard
that the judge has excluded them uh for
excuse them from jury service for the
rest of their lives now
why did this couple do this well um
they said that they'd
put in this punishment regime because of
arthur's behaviour
and
tustin had said that she simply couldn't
cope with his behavior hughes admitted
that he probably valued his partner's
love
over the welfare of his child